i'm going to give you guys a tour of the
last 24 hours of republicans on the
floor of the house and the floor of the
senate okay
when i've been saying
say when i've been reminding people
that the right has abandoned policy that
this new sort of breed of trumpist
doesn't even pretend to be about
anything other than pr and tweeting and
memes
um i didn't literally expect that there
would be a day where they just hold up
printouts of memes on the floor of the
house and even on the floor of the
senate but that day came yesterday
and we're going to look at some examples
here and we're going to talk about
the real underlying problem here because
this is really a societal problem if
this stuff didn't work to get people
elected if it was laughable wait hold on
you just do tweets and memes obviously
we're not voting for you if that was the
case
then this stuff wouldn't exist because
they never would have made it to the
floor of the house what am i talking
about well let's just start with
marjorie taylor green
marjory taylor green spent the day
yesterday on the floor of the house
with oversized printouts of different
memes
and
talking about how the memes are real and
this is completely beyond parody so
here's the first one this is a meme
where um
there is a uh
i can't i'm describing memes for the
audio audience this one is a two-frame
meme that says let's see who this really
is and it's a prisoner
with a blindfold that says green new
deal on it and then when they remove the
blindfold i guess that's the hammer and
sickle of communist china you know i
need to check know your meme i guess
here's marjorie taylor green this is a
simple meme that you would find on the
internet but this meme is very real the
green new deal surprise
is serves china and china only you can
go ahead and put number one up
so today talking about the green new
deal and the all-out war on the men okay
they're they're doing
you know i would respect a sort of like
powerpoint presentation
if it was substantive like when senators
and members of congress pull out charts
and graphs of different data and they
understand it and they understand how
these you know different economic
elements relate to all other that's fine
they're they're putting up pictures it's
like this is the house equivalent of
trump's uh daily presidential daily
briefing
instead of being many pages they cut it
down to a couple pages and he still
wouldn't read it so they cut it down to
one page
and then they cut it down to a page half
of which was like a chart and then two
or three bullet points this is the half
the the floor of the house version of
that uh marjorie taylor green continued
then here is the next meme
here is one
um
which says i own joe biden
and now i own afghanistan's lithium
deposits and the idea is that it's china
loving the fact that biden got out of
afghanistan i guess marjorie taylor
green wanted to stay there even though
trump wanted to leave and she's a
trumpist because it's all incoherent
i find it pretty shocking that people
actually think that members of congress
and their legislation is actually going
to control the earth's temperature or
temperature
um so this is now going on about climate
change and again it's just marjorie
taylor green on the floor of the house
with memes here's a bonus meme from the
senate this was also yesterday this is
senator joni ernst also kind of of the
same vein
slightly less cartoonish than marjorie
taylor green
but almost as ignorant she also puts up
a meme and she says this is a popular
meme i've actually never seen this one
this one seems to be
um
they're almost like are those go fish
cards or uno cards
that say uh trillion and 1.9 trillion
for the stimulus bill 1.2 trillion i
guess it's about making fun of
democratic spending or something that
this i'm sorry and then she puts up
another one
that uh
it's just all it's all pathetic mario
reminds me of this popular meme
of a guy playing uno okay it was uno and
it's just about democratic spending
guys it's it's not an exaggeration
republicans in the house and senate
yesterday
their arguments and their presentations
are they put up printouts of memes
and they say see guys this is what
democrats are doing these are their
critiques
um
this is the bigger issue
of the memification of the republican
party we've talked about increasingly
absent of policy
they are literally showing memes it
proves that point now just a couple
other examples just of the low level of
discourse these aren't memes but this is
just the idiocy that we've come to to
see on a regular basis here's
congressman mike lee he is taking issue
with the fact that
when the cdc
counts causes of death they don't
include abortion as a cause of death
why would that be well because abortion
is not considered death
like dying from covet
that's that's why okay here's mike lee
states and i just want to go over this
because i think sometimes we become
disillusioned with which what is
actually happening oh yeah the national
center for health statistics at the
centers for disease control and
prevention reports on the leading causes
of death in the united states but does
not include abortion among their list of
causes of death
right
that's his gripe so this is again
another one of these issues of
why are we even talking about this and
people watch it and think this is valid
political discourse and when we've
talked about
the sequelae of trumpism
whether trump goes away comes back or
doesn't
one of the things we have to contend
with and we're seeing it i mean these
are examples of it are that the
coarsening of discourse under donald
trump
has made it so that these types of
presentations on the floors of the house
and senate memes and why does an
abortion count as a cause of death all
of this stuff it's considered valid
politicking for many republicans even
though you and i hopefully see it for
what it is which is just meaningless
garbage
just one more example here here's
trumpian congresswoman lauren bobert
she's making the point
that victims of rape
need access to guns not access to
abortions
okay
lie number two
rape victims need abortions wrong they
need love they need support
they need safety and healing they needed
a glock 19 when it happened
right
um and this of course the context is
the situation with the extremely
restrictive abortion law
passed in texas and the debate that's
been generated over that how do we
recover from this and what i mean by
that is how do you turn around
after five years of the political
discourse being
your fake news
where is my african-american
um
what about injecting the hitting the
body with light and heat
uh and all of these all these different
pocahontas and all of this stuff it's
now just the republican party that's
what it is and
one of the things would be if both sides
were having substantive adult
discussions about important issues and
then we focus on the substance
we don't even have that because the
right is holding up memes on the floor
of the house of representatives and the
senate and talking about abortion should
be listed as a cause of death and this
type of thing i don't know how we turn
it around and uh you know hopefully to
some degree our conversation with lee
mcintyre was informative in terms of how
to de-cultify
uh but this is gonna be a real real big
uphill battle
one of our sponsors is atlas vpn in the
year 2021 many computer security experts
say everybody everybody should be using
a vpn whenever you connect to the
internet atlas vpn keeps your
information private from big tech
companies from your internet service
provider even from governments atlas vpn
helps you stay protected from hackers
trying to steal your data an atlas vpn
even lets you watch shows and movies on
netflix and other streaming services you
would otherwise only be able to access
from other countries i use atlas vpn on
all of my devices phone computer tablet
whenever i'm connected to the internet
it's so easy to use you sign up install
it turn it on and you're done out of
sight out of mind you stay protected and
right now my audience can get atlas vpn
for a dollar 39 a month
with a 30 day money back guarantee you
just have to go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video